do you know many people right now should
absolutely stop working and be the stay
stay-at-home parent full-time cuz it's
their greatest gift and calling and
greatest ability but we don't talk about
those things in society we don't give
that permission to a dad right we don't
give that permission in society to a SE
27y old guy who's listening to this
right now or 38y old guy who's listening
to this right now and knows in his heart
that he's so
paternal
so like built to parent so nurturing and
naturing and is so capable of producing
and molding and building tremendous
children with self-esteem and happiness
but he or she doesn't feel the
permission to do that because we're not
having that layer of conversation we're
having get stuff make money accomplish
and like I think people lack
self-awareness and self-confidence to do
the things they should or can be or want
to be doing and I think about that a lot